this video is sponsored by brilliant but
more on them later so you want to start
on the amazing quest of becoming a
computational neuroscientist one of the
first skills you will need to learn is
programming in computational
Neuroscience programming is not just a
tool that we use but it's also a
foundational element of how the brain is
viewed to operate in the book The
computational Brain it is said that the
expression computational and
computational Neuroscience reflects the
role of a computer as a research tool in
modeling complex systems such as
networks ganglia and brains with the
deep-seated conviction that what is
being modeled by a computer is in itself
a kind of computer so hi I'm Charlotte
rasa a second year PhD student in
computational neuroscience and today I
really want to talk about programming
and how to learn programming for
computational Neuroscience so I already
talked a little bit about the
mathematics of computational
Neuroscience and also about
computational Neuroscience itself and
how to learn it from scratch but a lot
of you have asked how exactly you get
the computational skills that are needed
for computational neuroscience and
especially if you are a beginner in
programming it is sometimes a little bit
overwhelming the amount of resources out
there but even if you're a little bit
more advanced in programming it may seem
that it's quite easy to get started on
computational Neuroscience but I think
there are some challenges that you will
need to overcome so in this video I will
give you a four-step pathway to learning
programming from scratch for
computational Neuroscience so the four
steps are to learn the basics of
programming fast and first then to find
a topic in computational Neuroscience
that really speaks to you or that you
like than to find a project within that
topic and lastly to get the knowledge to
fulfill this project or topic and I also
made a blog post of the entire pathway
that you can find Down Below on my
finally launched website and I also if
you're interested in Neuroscience you
can also subscribe to the email list and
I will try to post something about
Neuroscience every single week such that
you can keep updated with the news on
Neuroscience but let's get straight into
the first step learning the basics fast
and first so if you want to learn
computational Neuroscience of course the
first thing you need to know is some
basic programming but what I've noticed
with students usually when they dive
into computational neuroscience and the
programming aspects they spend months
learning the syntax of different
languages trying to really deeply
understand different algorithms but the
big problem with this is that even
though if you understand the theoretical
aspect of a certain algorithm it is
sometimes very different to apply this
algorithm in the real world and that is
because real neural Imaging data is
messy it's not structured and you will
have to alter your algorithm to fit your
project so for example if you want to
apply a k-means algorithm to MRI data
you need to think about the
pre-processing what kind of data you're
going to use and all of these things
will change how your K means l algorithm
will look like in the end that's why the
first step I would always recommend is
to learn the basics of programming first
and fast so in computational
Neuroscience there are in general two
languages that are mainly being used and
that is RM Python and I usually
recommend to my students to try python
first and that's because I noticed that
python is a little bit more intuitive
there are a lot more resources online
and I think it's a little bit easier in
the syntax so if you want to Learn
Python and you've never done python
before there are two beginner courses
that I quite like the first one is
hundred days of code I recommended it
before but I think it's an amazing
course that really takes you through all
the aspects of python and at the end
there are also a few projects that you
can try your skills on yourself and
another one that I came across recently
is this specialization in Python from
Coursera I think if you have a little
bit more time this is maybe also a nice
way to go because the specializations
and the courses from Coursera you can
also upload them to your LinkedIn and
kind of show that you've learned these
skills which I personally think is
really nice and I will link down all the
resources below for if you want to try
any of these out so after you've deep
dived into one of these courses some of
the libraries that you probably should
know are for example numpy pandas SK
learn Skippy and amongst others I think
there are many libraries in Python and
it will depend a lot on the project that
you will finally choose which libraries
you really need to know so after you've
got these basic python skills down I do
think there are a few other programming
skills that are just kind of nice if you
also get before you really dive deep
into your project and that is to set up
a GitHub first so why I always recommend
to use GitHub is it's just such a nice
place to put all your code and if you
ever want to share your code you can do
this on GitHub it's kind of this open
science open data library for your own
code so this is just a really a good way
to manage your own code and also to
share it with others another skill that
I would definitely dive into a little
bit is the command line and how to use
the command line so if you use a Linux
computer you probably know what the
command line is but on Mac or Windows
you can also access the command line and
through the command line you can for
example create different folders or you
can read certain folders at a certain
post structure and it is kind of nice
and a good skill to have to get used to
working with the terminal a little bit
and that is because with Neuroscience we
use a lot of really big data files and
sometimes it's nicer to manage these
files from the terminal it's a lot
faster and a little bit less messy and
error prone than if you have to do
everything by hand and the last tool
that I would also recommend to learn is
Jupiter notebook so I use Jupiter
notebooks a lot I think they are perfect
for science because in between your
coding blocks you also have these little
explanation blocks and especially if you
ever want to share your code or or you
want to use your code for science this
is a really nice and intuitive way to
combine code with explanations so in
general I would really try to pick one
course for Python and stick to it and
then learn these other skills and I
wouldn't take more than two to three
months to learn these skills because
there's always more to learn and if you
don't put yourself on a straight
deadline before you know it you spend
four years learning different
programming skills but you haven't even
touched any Neuroscience data yet and
the big thing with courses is that
usually the data they give you is nicely
curated and perfect for you to use in a
project but real life data is actually
really messy and to really get used to
it and to get over frustrations and to
learn how to push through when coding
gets hard that's why you need to go to
step two and that's to pick a topic in
Neuroscience so step two is to find a
topic that you like within computational
Neuroscience so when you first start
entering in computational Neuroscience
you may think that it's a really
homogeneous field but if you actually
work in computational Neuroscience you
will learn quite quickly that the way
you approach computational Neuroscience
is really vast and quite different so
the things you can learn and the topics
you can choose in computational
Neuroscience are really diverse so for
example you can choose a particular area
of the brain you want to study so you
could choose the visual cortex the motor
cortex the prefrontal cortex or you
could look at different levels of
organization so for example you could
look at synapses neurons or large-scale
networks also the type of questions you
want to answer will really dictate how
your research will go so your questions
can be about the biological mechanisms
underlying the brain or you just want to
look at behavior and how your brain
signals correlate with certain
behavioral patterns or maybe you want to
make a predictive model that can
separate people with a certain type of
mental disorder from healthy population
and these type type of questions were
really dictate the type of data and the
type of algorithms you will use so then
you might think like how am I gonna pick
a topic if the field is so diverse so I
wouldn't recommend to pick a book
because I think a lot of the
computational Neuroscience books even
though they're really nice they're
usually a little bit outdated because
the field moves so fast so the thing
that I usually recommend people to do if
they're interested in computational
neuroscience and they also want to
really understand the field is to follow
their favorite researchers on Twitter
and this is because most researchers
publish their latest papers or their
latest reviews on Twitter and by
following your favorite researchers on
Twitter you kind of get your own curated
little newsletter every day or every
week from the latest Neuroscience news
so also in the blog post that I made and
it's linked down below I listed 10
neuroscientists that you can follow
right now and kind of see where they're
at but of course I wouldn't stop at
decent neuroscientists I just kind of
picked them randomly because I really
like their work but also look at the
people they are following and by doing
this you kind of get an organic and more
natural overview of the field of
computational Neuroscience so for
example if we look at three papers that
I found recently that I really like in
different areas of computational
Neuroscience we will see the different
skills that you will need to develop
first maybe you want to look at machine
learning so there's this paper called
comparisons of deep neural networks to
spatial temporal cortical dynamics of
human visual object recognition reveals
hierarchical correspondence so they
really wanted to look how functional MRI
signals related to artificial deep
neural networks that they trained on the
same type of visual data so the skills
that you would need to create something
like this is of course to make a deep
neural network but you also need to
understand and be able to curate
functional MRI data and to form a 2d
surface-based Searchlight analysis so
another paper in a different field
altogether is in dynamical systems and
this paper is called a simple circuit
model of visual cortex explains neural
and behavioral aspects of attention so
the type of skills you would need for
this is quite different so you of course
need to be able to make a simple model
circuit or a stabilized super linear
Network an SSN also you need to know
about different theories of attention
that come from psychology for example
and they also used convolutional neural
networks and the last field that I quite
like and I'm quite following some papers
in that is in reinforcement learning so
this is a paper that is called
prefrontal cortex as a meta
reinforcement learning system and I
would highly recommend reading this it's
quite interesting so they really drawed
on recent advances in artificial
intelligence to introduce a new theory
of reward-based learning and if thing or
the skills that you would need for a
paper like this is to know reinforcement
learning they also use some concept of
entropy and they used a little bit
standard Concepts in machine learning
such as gradient descent and prep
propagation and as you can see the
skills that you need for these topics
are sometimes overlapping but sometimes
they are really different and if you try
to learn all the skills that are
available in computational Neuroscience
you will probably spend a couple of
years really deep diving into it and you
will at the end have not applied
anything and I think it's really easy to
then also forget what you have learned
so after you've read about a month maybe
every day a different paper on the topic
try to really think about what inspires
you and what really attracts you and
also something that I always recommend
people to do is to look at the
limitations section of different papers
because the limitation section usually
gives you a really good idea of the
limitations of the field and also where
you as a possible future researcher
could contribute to so after you picked
a topic and you have your programming
skills it's onto step three which is to
find a project to really apply your
newly found programming skills and to
really discover the topic that
interested you a little bit so I think
in general there are a lot of benefits
to project-based learning but before
that I really consider super beneficial
are that you will learn exactly what you
need you will come in contact with the
messiness of real data you can
immediately reinforce your learning with
coding and also you will have a project
at the end that you can put in your CV
or GitHub to really show people the kind
of skills that you have and the kind of
things that you learned so in general it
is kind of hard to find a project in
Neuroscience if you are not affiliated
with a lab but there are some ways that
I'm gonna teach you now that range from
beginner level to a little bit more
advanced such that you can all hopefully
get a project at the end so the first
thing you can do is to look at summer
school so for example I worked at a
summer school last summer for neuromatch
and it's amazing summer school where
they take you over all the topics in
conversational Neuroscience but you also
get the chance to work on a project for
about three weeks and they give you
access to a lot of data so for example I
worked with this group on fmri data from
the human connection project and they're
kind of projects they came up with I was
really impressed because it was of a
really high level so that's probably a
really good beginner friendly option to
apply to different summer schools in
Neuroscience that also have a
project-based learning aspects so the
second thing you can look at are these
kind of kaggle competitions I personally
really like that goal it is sometimes a
little bit difficult to find something
that's particular for Neuroscience but
they have a lot of data science
competitions and projects that you can
work on and I do think data science and
Neuroscience are actually quite similar
so if you get some skills on a kaggle
company decision you can usually then
apply those skills to a more serious
project later then the third option is
to look at hackathons so in Neuroscience
there are a lot of hackathons available
online sometimes you have to apply so
sometimes you do have to be a student
but for example one hackathon that I
really like if is from ohbm and I will
list it down below and it's just a
really nice hackathon that a lot of
people apply to in the field of
computational Neuroscience so the fourth
thing you can look at are these open
source coding projects so I will list a
few down below but it is sometimes a
little bit harder to really get into
these so I think this is a more advanced
option and that's because a lot of the
tools that were created for
computational Neuroscience have been
created over so many years that the code
is quite complex to understand as a
beginner then another thing you can do
of course is to apply at a lab for a lab
rotation so for example when I was in my
masters I emailed a few professors with
the kind of skills I had and especially
if you are already a little bit better
at programming or you have worked in a
lab previously a lot of professors do
want to give you the opportunity to work
with them for six months or a year and I
think this is a really nice way to learn
a lot in a short amount of time and even
if you are in your undergraduate and you
think I don't have any skills it's
always nice to email a professor just to
show them that you've really read that
work you're interested you already
learned some programming and usually
they are quite kind and they sometimes
will give you an amazing opportunity
then the last thing you can try but I do
think this is sometimes a little bit
more advanced but is to apply for an
internship at a company so there are
different companies in computational
Neuroscience that also have internships
listed online so for example you can
think of Google AI Facebook AI say no or
the Allen Institute and these are just a
few that I mentioned from the top of my
head but there are of course a lot of
other companies and by getting an
internship and a company your growth
Curve will be like super steep and you
will learn a lot and then it's to the
fourth and final step but I also
sometimes called is the beginning step
and that's because now it's time to find
the knowledge that you need for your
projects so probably if you've now found
a project you will quickly realize all
the skills that you are missing and
instead of thinking oh I'm gonna give up
I'm not good enough for this project
this is actually where most good
programmers come from so you will make a
list of all the skills that you will
need for your specific project and then
Deep dive into them so for example for
the work that I'm currently doing and if
Master students apply to our lab usually
the things that you will need to know
are how to use a glm so General linear
models how to do dimensionality
reduction with PCA or ICA how to do deep
learning so we're working a lot with
auto encoders nowadays and also a little
bit mcmc how to do graph Theory so graph
theory is quite important and also
patient statistics is used a lot in our
lab which we call normative modeling so
usually I recommend my students to take
the machine learning course by Andrew
nguing which is also down below and
which is also down below and he also has
this amazing machine learning
specialization that I highly recommend
if you're going in a field of
computational Neuroscience that uses a
little bit more machine learning but
then again for a different type of
Neuroscience project you may need
entirely different skills and this is
really the point where you're learning
Journey will actually start and will
also really start to diverge from other
people's Learning Journey so for example
Maxwell Cohen said even if we did know
about all the synapses all the
transmitters all the channels all the
response patterns for each cell and so
forth still we would not know how an
animal sea smells and walks and I think
this really shows where computational
Neuroscience is at at the moment we know
so much but we also still know so little
so there's still so much more to uncover
and to learn about the brain and I'm
just really excited for you if you're
gonna start on this journey to join us
in how to learn about the brain and all
the amazing things there is to learn
about it so also to update your
programming skills a little bit further
I would also highly recommend brilliant
I've been using brilliant for a little
while now and I especially like their
course on computer science fundamentals
so I usually have this rule that I'm not
really allowed to procrastinate when I'm
coding or doing anything serious for my
science but I am sometimes allowed to
learn in another way and one way that I
use is brilliant nowadays so for example
I'm really deep diving into the
fundamentals of programming and where
some of the ideas actually come from
because I'm not from a programming
background my bachelor was in physics so
I don't know that much about the
fundamentals of programming so I am
really enjoying Brilliance to learn
about these kind of skills and I think
this is one of the things I really
appreciate about brilliant they don't
really shy away from really difficult
topics and they explain it in a really
nice and intuitive manner so to get
started for free visits brilliant.org
Charlottes or click the link in the
description down below the first 200 of
you will get 20 of brilliant's annual
premium subscription so every day if I'm
bored instead of checking YouTube or
Twitter I usually spend some time on the
app Brilliance so if you've sticked
around till this long thank you and I
really hope you start learning a little
bit more about compositional
Neuroscience I'm also planning for the
upcoming months to make a few more
tutorial Style videos about
computational Neuroscience so if you
have any things you're curious about or
want to learn please put it down in the
comments below and otherwise see you
next week bye